[Music]
add wine that's an 1800 i don't think we
played too many of these
okay let's go knight f6 and a london
system i love playing well i like
playing against london it's very
pertinent a lot of you guys need a
little bit of instruction of playing
against the london
now
here's the thing
the system that you choose against the
london depends entirely on what you play
against d4 and c4
if you're a queen's gambit player you
should play d5 here if you're a king's
indian player you should play g6 or a
grunfeld player
um if you're a benoni player you can
play c5 if you're a queen's indian
player you can go b6 there are a lot of
good moves here the move that i like a
little bit less is e6 i feel like it's a
little bit inflexible let's play a very
conventional london system uh in this
particular game because i think it
overlaps probably with what most of you
play we're going to play d5 we're going
to play d5 and see what he does
i'm going to show you guys a very
ambitious way to play against the london
system to challenge it from a
theoretical standpoint
okay usually of course if i play as e3 i
can also play knight f3
or c3 doesn't matter
yeah so we'll talk about the subtleties
here in terms of developing this bishop
but generally if you fiancato you should
play it with d6 you shouldn't play a
grunfeld setup proper
okay so
in this position
once again there are many possible moves
you can play e6 that's the sort of
modest setup the move that i really like
here
and this really challenges the london is
is c5 i'm sure people have seen this
move before
it you know it allows white to take on
c5 and taking on c5 is one of the main
moves but it's very ambitious it's
mainstream you're immediately contesting
the center you're basically playing it
like a queen's gambit with black
and c3 is very much in the spirit of the
london
so now black doesn't do anything
extraordinary we keep the tension we go
knight c6 now clearly taking on c5 here
is already not as sensible because what
does black have what very nice way does
black have of regaining the pawn after d
takes e5 here and that is partially why
we put the knight on c6
uh of course there's e5 with tempo
occupying the center and then the bishop
moves we take on c5
so at this point white should continue
the development knight d2 is good
uh knight f3 is very commonly played
isn't it and as far as i remember is
inaccurate
so yeah he does play knight d2 good job
by my opponent
now um once again there's such a wide
choice in such positions it's hard for
me to talk about like this is the best
line i can only tell you guys what i've
seen and what i like
and the the the particular move here
that i like because this leads to a
structure which a lot of people struggle
with uh in this rating range is is queen
to b6
it's queen to b6 now what is the
function of this move well clearly we're
applying pressure on the spawn you guys
have seen this a million times uh this
kind of central this kind of tension
between the queens
and
first question is of course should we
take white's queen since i'm asking that
question you probably know the answer is
no why not because it allows white to
take with the pawn
and this a file that semi-open a file is
actually very very important i'll show
you guys why we want to be the ones to
control the a file ourselves and so we
encourage the trade with the move c4 now
experienced london players will not take
the queen but will drop the queen back
to c2 leading to a
well he does take the queen uh which i
like because this is a structure i'm
sure a lot of you guys have gotten
before and i think a course in how to
play this with the black side might be
really really helpful i think
so
a3 is good
uh a3 is a good move he's playing this
in the way that he should now black has
an idea here that
really is the most typical
idea it's one of the reasons why this
kind of structure favors the side that
controls the semi-open file does anybody
know what this plan is it
it hinges on the fact that the rook on a
one is undefended we have a standoff
between the rooks
so we can employ that fact in order to
quickly push our queen side pawns we can
try to steamroll him
by playing b5
which is good as a standalone move
because it it supports the c4 pawn he
just wandered upon here but in addition
what i want you guys to notice is that
we are threatening to go b5 to b4
c takes b4 and then knight takes b4 and
we basically break through
that initial layer of his defense
uh the knight is untouchable because the
rook hangs on a1 and i'll talk about
that more afterward he tries to break in
the center but that's a nonsensical move
unless i don't know some
latest theory we can take this either
with the knight or with the pawn
now which way should we take it
well i don't see a reason not to take it
just with the pawn maybe it doesn't
really matter to be honest bishop g5
so he's trying to win back the pawn he's
trying to take on f6 and then take on e4
so maybe we should have we should have
probably taken with a knight but
still we're gonna get a desirable
position here even if he ends up winning
the pawn so what should we do here
how should we deal with this
the move is quite straightforward i
think
we should begin by playing
what move i mean can we defend the spawn
can we make it hard for him
no no no no but the situation has
changed guys because if you look at b4
concretely now the c4 pawn is hanging
in this case the d5 pawn
uh was defending c4 here
b4 makes a lot less sense we should
instead focus on defending e4 we should
go bishop f5
okay so he plays 92 yeah so it was a
small inaccuracy by me to take with the
knight
okay so where is this knight going well
clearly this knight is going to g3
and
we have a sort of very typical
prophylactic move we can start by
dropping the bishop back to g6 uh and
basically the purpose of this move is to
get him to show his cards he goes knight
g3 okay now we know what he what he
wants to do and we can orient toward
that situation
all right so
one way to think about this is that
we actually kind of have a lead in
development here we have
a space advantage
we have better place pieces and
currently we're up a pawn and in order
to regain the pawn he's going to have to
spend a couple of moves he's going to
have to take here and then he's going to
have to take on e4 and that's pretty
significant so
let's think logically for a second what
do we do
when we've got a space advantage and
we've got better development in the
middle game well we try to open up the
center right that's kind of the rule
now we've already established that b4
doesn't work because it drops the c4
pawn is there any other way to open up
the center before he gets a chance to
develop his king side yeah that's the
move e5 hopefully i've explained this in
a logical way what's going to happen
hopefully uh is that once he gives up
his bishop
our two bishops are going to be very
valuable in the open position
and the fact that we have a very easy
way to castle if we need to and he i
guess also can cancel along but it's not
quite as effective yeah he takes we take
uh and and his position is starting to
already kind of collapse here
okay so here we have a very instructive
mode
now obviously
we could take on e5 and we are better
black is better there's no doubt in my
mind
but
if we look very carefully there should
be a move which comes to you if we just
sort of look at the center very very
closely
what can we do how can we resolve the
central tension to our favor
this pawn on e5 is a sitting duck
so
maybe we can support the pawn on e4 yes
f5
driving the pawn down creating a pawn
chain
and the e5 pawn is going to be toast we
get the best of all worlds
h4 now let's not fall asleep he wants to
play h5 and trap our bishop that means
we should play h5 ourselves
that means we should play h5 ourselves
okay
f3 so
my intuition is sort of telling me okay
this is his position is starting to
crumble here so we should be very
attentive to these very specific
opportunities that present themselves we
have a beautiful sexy move here don't
just grab the pawn automatically
definitely don't take on f3 because that
allows his knight into the game
what is the obvious move here this is
supernatural e3
and then we're gonna follow that up with
f4 and look at that pawn chain which is
gonna be created that pawn is not going
anywhere
okay i have four i don't think we have a
mildly bad position black is certainly
better
i have four
and i think when i'm worse i'm usually
pretty honest about i mean i try to be
honest about it now maybe i'm worse and
i don't know about it but
okay so now we got to be a little bit
careful if knight takes c5 then knight
takes up or if i've already kind of
given away the move that we should play
the base of the pawn chain is f4 that's
the pawn that we want to protect right
if we lose that pawn then who's to say
that e3 is not going to follow along so
the simplest move is to get the bishop
out to h6
and i'm going to write this concept down
because it's very important
and very misunder very commonly
misunderstood i'm going to talk about it
after the game
the sort of question well isn't the
bishop bad here
okay so how should we finish the game
what options are available to us
we can trade in rook d8 we can trade in
rook d and basically win the pawn
we can take a more uh a less
materialistic approach we can play
knight takes e5 and and swing the knight
over to d3
i think that um
that's probably the best we played
knight takes c5 i don't give a damn
about the spawn anymore let him take it
just don't blunder the fork
yeah so we can either castle
yeah you know we can castle i was
thinking even rook d8 also and knight d3
is coming with completely devastating
effect because
obviously when he take okay well that's
that's a free bishop and that's the game
yeah
and he resigns that's a that's a good
game
okay
so
yeah so london system
e3 c5 now if you look at my games with
white in the london and i've played the
london a good amount in classical in
classical games
uh i think that the most ambitious move
for white is to take the pawn
and
what you guys might be seeing here is oh
well black can recover the pawn with
queen a5 check right
but after knight c3 queen takes e5 we
made two moves with the queen
and white's got some nasty ideas here
for example bishop takes b8 is a move
rook takes b8 but should be five check
and it turns out the black is going to
have to lose castling rights because if
you cover with the bishop
you know and then you take with a knight
well the d5 pawn falls and that's a
healthy extra pond for white so what's
up paula
um
you know so in this position black has
to be a lot more crafty
as to how you try to win this pawn and
black has a couple of different lines e6
is possible here white tries to cling to
the pawn you get this super interesting
complicated kind of position
uh where where usually black ends up
sacking the pawn for
queen side pressure you guys can
investigate this yourselves
um
but it's it's a very interesting line
there's also knight c6
uh trying to get e5 in and white goes
bishop b5 preventing e5 by pinning the
knight
this does not win a bishop because of
knight c3
um
and i'm a little bit
uh rusty on the theory here but i think
e6 is still the move in this position e6
before
um a5 c3
like a b c b bishop d7 again
black tries to soften up this punch in
and he sacrifices upon um
i think i wrote a chess-based article
about this a while ago so
it's it's really really interesting
stuff
um so c3
knight c6
and also this is why i like blank c5
because london system players generally
like something very systematic uh they
like something you know
again like something systemic something
that that that offers up a sequence of
moves that are predictable and when you
get a uh
you know when you get this kind of
tactical position it forces your
opponent to depart from the system
uh which is really you know you're
basically playing the psychology of the
opening okay
so knight c6 knight f3 knight d2 this is
the more traditionally london-esque way
of playing queen b6 queen b3 and c4 so
hopefully i did a decent job explaining
why this is desirable for white despite
the fact that these are double pawns
um
you know and and to some of you asking
well how do we know
that the semi-open file that white has
is more valuable than the doubled pawns
uh you know how do we know that it's not
outweighed by the double sponsor that's
like winning the lottery
and you know getting a suitcase full of
hundred dollar bills and then saying
well
you know that 100 bill's a little bit
crumpled it's a little bit you know it's
not new enough
the double pawns are okay that's a weird
analogy thank you matt for the gifted
sub the doubled pawns are not inherently
bad they're not weak they're well
defended
they can move uh forward as a unit in
fact they could be good
so you don't want to do that you don't
want to play queen b3 unless you have to
and
so we play c4 we try to trade on our own
terms and
queen c2 is the move that i'm familiar
with
so
as far as i remember
thank you pistol cat this leads to a
structure of course where you guys can
identify the pawn chain and generally
speaking white has two ways of trying to
break down this pawn chain he can attack
the bass with e4 that's the sort of
traditional method or you can play b3
that's the sort of faster method
and and that aims to trade the c4 pawn
so that your bishop can come out to a
good london square on d3 so i was going
to play g6 here preparing the
development of the bishop to f5 i think
white has a slight edge here if he plays
accurately
um again i'm not too well versed in the
theory here because i myself play the
king's indian set up against the london
so i never studied this formally
with black but i thought it was an
interesting
uh chance to look at some closed
positions okay so if you're a london
system player
i'm pretty sure you should play queen c2
all right so queen takes b6 a takes b6
a3 is good
and now we play b5 so again we're trying
to play b4 and breakthrough
uh in the time that the rook is still
undefended and if you look at the way
that this unfolds at a high level
white generally
should bring the rook away from a1
in order to
disallow the possibility of b4 because
now of course after cb
this is useless there's no rook on a1
anymore right
and in this position black is a very
nasty plan that i was introduced to
years and years ago
and i remember
vividly like the first time i faced this
kind of a plan
and it really opened my eyes to the fact
that even though white's position looks
incredibly solid
there are these hidden
uh avenues of attack that black has
which come completely out of nowhere so
how should this proceed first you start
with bishop f5 developing move right
cowboy thank you for the prime okay
let's say white plays knight f3
now
i would say that black should probably
start with e6 and then h6 just to make
the uh improving move so let's see e6 h6
e6 castles
and black's main idea is to go 97.
can anybody identify
where the knight is going here thank you
john perfect perfect timing we'll do the
speed run
thank you hey guys
got my t here thank you john i
appreciate it we just did our first game
of the speed run for tonight we'll be
ending soon but you guys joined as we're
analyzing a classic london system
structure
and i'm showing some typical plans here
for black yes knight b6 knight a4 and
guess what the role of the bishop on f5
is to cover the b1 square so the rook
can't go to b1
so let's say that white
you know dithers around h3 and ip6
hey guys
let's get the knight to a4 you know when
the pawn and then get flagged
so this pawn is indefensible you cannot
defend the spawn white's position
totally collapses
which means that white has to kind of
play bishop d1 here you might say no
problem bishop d1
knight a4 bishop takes a4
now what should black capture with and
with what aim and this is the secondary
idea and i think this is actually genius
because this pawn on b2 it doesn't seem
accessible and yet it is and that's a
hint
that's a big hint
and again i'm talking more generally
here specifically white might have
counter play in this position with e4
but i'm trying to show the general ideas
you want to play pawn takes a4 not to
undouble the pawns that's not the point
the point is to lift the rook either to
a b5 or to b6
uh and and that's quite amazing this
pawn on b2 is again going to be in
tremendous amount of trouble now because
this bishop is operating uncontested on
the light squares
so
just with a quick chess based search i
can probably find a hundred games that
feature this exact plan
you know in fact that's exactly what i'm
going to do just to show you guys that
i'm not making this stuff up it happens
in real games between real real players
um let me do a quick search see if i can
find
this exact kind of idea with the rook
the rook left after night knight b6
knight a4
okay so basically what i was going to
show
uh real real fast is a game which
basically featured these exact ideas
slightly different you know wearing
slightly different clothes i would say
but
uh but the ideas are identical
um
all right sorry i have temporary ocd so
d4 you can see a london
c5 this is actually no this is basically
the same one bishop f5 here was played
first and in this order black basically
tricked white white doesn't have the
retreat to c2 so at this point you have
to go for uh oh it's thank you for the
gift and idenov you have to go for the
trade you also can't go queen a3
because of the the straightforward e5
and this is a discovery against the
queen and f4 is falling as well
so queen takes b6 ab6 a3b5
rook c1 so white has the recognition to
play rook c1
so here's h6 like i said
uh just to make sure that in the event
of knight h4 you have this uh much like
white does in the london you have h7 for
the bishop and why do you need to keep
the bishop on this diagonal well as i
said you want to make sure that white's
rook can never get to b1 this becomes
important when you start attacking the
b2 pawn so it's all interconnected
knight d7 knight b6
knight a4 you guys can see takes takes
e6
now black begins by expanding and now
black to play
if you guys have been paying careful
attention
what should black do in this position
yeah so rook a6 okay six
rook b6 now white found a very ingenious
idea here which is knight before
so this guy is not
going down without a fight but what
basically ends up happening here
is that black forces a transformation of
the structure that will be in his favor
and if a takes b4 then i think
you know a long-term plan for black you
can stick the bishop on d3 and black
could even consider the the sacrifice a3
why because ultimately
uh white black's going to park a rook on
a4 and black is a very simple plan
you're going to get the king out the
bishop out you're going to double on the
a file look at how passive white's
position is i think you're ultimately
not going to be able to stop the
infiltration of the rook to a3
uh i don't think there's well i think
that's the difference right if you had
gone rook a5
uh then you know if you consider the
same line
right if you compare the two you
literally compare the two positions
you've got a rook on b6 okay so what's
the difference oh here the rook can come
to a6 here the rook doesn't have a5 so i
think in this case black played
accurately by playing rook a6 and
if y goes bishop c7 then white black can
just get the bishop out of there with
king d7 that's a good question though
so this kind of comparison can be really
helpful like detecting nuances so black
white takes cb
but very similarly
you know black's got this white sprung a
leak
white has sprung a leak
and um
king d7 happens white panics with e4 and
like allows black to open up the
position and black just very textbook
styles look at e5 i mean such a textbook
win just beautiful and white resigned
here
now i think white had more resilient
ways of defending white shouldn't have
opened up the position with e4
white should have probably tried to get
the rook to c3
although black is clearly pushing here i
mean black and try to go f65
um and if i were black i would have
considered
uh much like the sacrifice a3 i would i
would have considered c3 and then rook
c6 and
and and you know same idea rook c or c4
and then rook c8 just i would have
calculated that
in any case
i could find better examples but you
guys can see this is real stuff these
ideas exist
and they can be very effectively used in
this end game
now obviously again i i want to make it
very clear that i'm idealizing this
in the sense that when you're playing
your own game
you have to be and because i can see
somebody doing this and saying well i
got crushed and daniel taught me all
these techniques and they're all crap
what do you need to watch out for if
you're playing black here well one of
the most important things is this e4
pawn break you have to be incredibly
vigilant about e4
here's an example of being naive
let's take the position before us that
came from
um
bishop d1 knight e4 takes takes
uh of course this didn't happen in the
game
uh and we'll get to what happened in the
game
if white plays rook f to e1 and then you
say ah now i'm gonna apply with daniel
tommy i'm gonna go rook a5 or rook a6 or
whatever
well that would be an example of not
looking at the position concretely
enough because here you would allow e4
you can't drop the bishop back because
after ed your king is pinned right and
after d e well that ruins the integrity
of your pawn structure it gives white a
lot of activity d5 becomes an idea right
so what should you do here how should
you play
to take the sting out of e4 because you
can't stop this move from happening but
you can try to take the sting out of it
what should you do
bishop d3 that's what i was thinking too
bishop d3 and if white plays e4
then what can you do in order to avoid
uh severing the link between the pawn
chain how can you
how can you keep this uh from falling
apart well you need to understand that
the point of the point is that we're
pinned that's the problem
just king d7 king d7 would be one way
takes takes
and if white tries 95 track takes and
then rook takes e5
beautiful move rook a5 both preparing
rook b5 and defending d5 you're also
threatening bishop d6 so black's
position is very solid as long as you
can
uh prioritize the concrete properties of
the position and
i think this might be one of the
reasons behind people thinking i've
learned you know i've learned a lot
and i appreciate people saying that but
you know if you find yours that you then
lose positions that i talked about one
of the reasons might be
that you're not paying sufficient
attention to
the differences between the position
that i had in the speed run and the
position you have
you have to allocate some mental energy
for that if that makes sense
okay
so let me see um
let's go back to the game of course my
opponent collapsed with e4 that's way
premature he just blunders upon
now i probably should have played knight
takes before like i said because then
this pawn is much harder to get to
but we played d e and then bishop f5
knight e2
okay so we drop the bishop back to g6
classic technique right we force him
to g3 and now boom goes the dynamite we
open up the position exploiting his lack
of development and his generally cramped
position
bishop f6 gf6 he should have taken on e4
here probably
although his position is miserable
um
yeah so if he had taken i would have
taken
this is probably what he should have
done takes takes
in 94.
now you look at this position you might
say well why is black even better you
know you have a bad pawn structure here
but i look at this position and say
black is almost winning
so
maybe you guys all see the black is
winning but
why is black why does my intuition say
that black is winning here well there's
a couple of factors that i kind of spot
intuitively
the first is after a move like long
castle black literally has a big lead in
development well white is uncastled
white's king is weak why it's king is
weak and there's a sense in which
white's pieces are sort of up in the air
the knight on e4 is a type 2 undefended
piece
black has the two bishop advantage
there's the e file the knight coming
into d3 do you guys kind of see how like
one single factor may not contribute to
black's advantage
uh to a great degree but taking together
all of these things mean that white's
position is on the verge of falling
apart
and so in this way i've
spelled out these reasons without really
calculating maybe if you do some
calculation you'll find that white is
okay but that's how you can use your
intuition to evaluate the position
well the reason my king is not weak is
because it's much harder to get to
his king is surrounded by open files and
outposts my king might be weak in a
global sense of the word if there were
queens on the board but without queens
on the board he has no way of getting to
my king i mean if he goes a4 tries to
open the a file at the very least i can
go b4 and keep things shut
the point of castling is to get the rook
involved it is not just to safeguard the
king it is to get the king out of the
way of the rook if that makes sense we
want the rook on
it's not that the king was unsafe here
it's that it was interfering in the
operations of my pieces
and if you go rook d8 they can't get
starts to dangle in front of the pieces
that you want to get active right
it's and that's one of the things which
is sometimes misunderstood you you don't
always castle to make your king safe
sometimes particularly in the end game
the primary function of castling is to
actually activate the rook remember that
that's also a thing that castling does
we associate castling with king safety
but it also gets the rook active
okay so that's what he should have done
he takes and now f5 is a critical move
supporting the pawn
preparing knight takes e5
h4 h5
and i want to talk for a second here
after f3 e3 f4 we drive in the pawn
wedge and we go bishop h6
i have a feeling without trying to put
words in people's mouths that some
players would hesitate to play this move
because the bishop looks bad on h6 like
doesn't the bishop just stare at the
pawn
and one of my favorite quotes is bad
bishops defend good pawns that's
originally i think formulated by
romanian gm mihai suba
and
i think i've described this before you
should think of this
not as a bad bishop and a good pawn but
as one unit this is like a single unit
it's like a single megapiece
the bishop and the pawn they can't exist
without each other
if you remove the pawn from f4 then this
whole construction is useless if you
remove the bishop then it's useless
because the pawn will fall
so
you need to see the bigger picture when
you isolate each piece
and view it in isolation and say well
the bishop is bad because it doesn't
control squares
then you're going to get the wrong
impression about the position sometimes
you have to see the bigger picture a
piece may look bad because it doesn't
control squares but it might be
protecting a pawn
that forms a crucial
building block of your position if that
makes sense
okay
the rest of the game was very
straightforward we take on e5 we castle
again not to safeguard the king but to
activate the rook to bring it to an open
file he blunted the bishop but if he
didn't look at how paralyzed he is he
can't get the night out
um and we're about to play knight d3 and
just totally crushing
[Music]